hi I'm Tom Sherlock I work in the
user-interface group here at Wolfram
research and today I'm talking about
stellar aperture photometry
ok let's get started huh
you can see mine my name is Tom Sherlock
I'm a user interface developer here at
Wolfram research I'm I'm not a
professional astronomer I'm that's my
hobby and so for the last several years
I've been talking about different
aspects of astronomy and astrophysics
previously I've my talks have been
basically devoted to improving the the
images I've been taking with my
telescope and trying to get better
pretty pictures well today's talk is
going to be more concentrate on on
getting actual data out of astronomical
images so it's going to be a little more
data centric so so what we're talking
about today is stellar aperture
photometry and this is basically the
technique of pulling brightness data out
of a series of astronomical images of a
star and there are many reasons why you
might might want to do this you can
learn interesting physics from the light
curve of a star including things like
for instance how how far away the star
is or if the star is an eclipsing binary
or you can learn things about the
dynamics of that system or if the star
is being eclipsed by an exoplanet you
can detect exoplanets that way so
there's a lot of very useful and
interesting information can be gained by
extracting light curves from
astronomical images and as it turns out
Wolfram language is an ideal package an
ideal tool for doing this because we
incorporate a lot of different things
which are useful to astronomers there's
a lot of image processing machinery
inside the Wolfram language and also we
have the ability to import astronomical
data and then do analysis on it so I'm
going to talk a little bit about
some of the things I've tried here and
we'll see how far we get so today we're
going to talk about CCD photometry and
the olden days photometry was basically
you'd hire a bunch of people and they
would look at big glass plates and try
to estimate the brightness of stars on
the the plates using microscopes and
stuff today we have CCD cameras so we
can actually just bring the data right
into our analysis system and so we're
going to do this and create a time
series of data and the example I'm going
to use has to do with the class of
variable star stars called Cepheid
variables Cepheid variable stars are
interesting because there's a strong
correlation between the star's light
curve and the Stars intrinsic brightness
or its absolute magnitude this
period-luminosity relationship which was
first published in 1912 it's called love
it's law after Henrietta Swan Leavitt
and based on her work at the Harvard
College Observatory she was one of these
people who crunched data in the early
part of the last century by reading it
right off of glass plates and this is
about the definition of tedious work as
far as I'm concerned and eventually
Henrietta worked her way up to being
paid 30 cents an hour for this initially
she wasn't paid anything to do this but
what she determined was for population 1
Cepheid x' there's a simple relationship
between the stars intrinsic brightness
it's absolutely magnitude and the period
of its light curve and so they're
related by the log base 10 so this is
called Levitz law and we can write in in
Mathematica
absolute magnitude is negative 2.8 1
times log base 10 of the period the
periods measured in days minus one point
four three and there there's more
complex versions of this formula if you
want to incorporate observations made in
infrared and visual bands this is
basically just the simplest form of so
that's we're gonna use right now so give
an example of this absolute magnitude of
Cepheid with the three day period is
going to be negative two point seven
seven eight quite bright and this is a
log linear plot of absolute magnitude of
the period you can see it's just a
straight line when plotted on a log
scale so if we have a measure of the
absolute magnitude of the star and since
we know that brightness falls off as
increasing distance from Earth if you
have the absolute mag to the star and
the apparent magnitude which you measure
from Earth you can get a pretty good
estimate of the distance in parsecs of
the star and this is just a power
relationship so you subtract the
magnitudes add five divide the sum by
five and raise that to base ten power
and that will give you the distance in
parsecs so we can combine the two
formulas and get a relationship which
will give you the distance in parsecs
from Earth to the Cepheid based on its
apparent magnitude observed from Earth
and its period in days so we're going to
try to perform this calculation before
we go any further we should also mention
Edwin Hubble
so in 1924 he used this relationship to
make a very significant discovery he
found
one of these Cepheid x' in what was then
believed to be the andromeda nebula
which was thought to be part of our
galaxy this is if you go out on a dark
night like in the summer you can see a
patch of light in the constellation
Andromeda it's near the great square of
Pegasus and this was thought to be part
of our own galaxy and the whole universe
was considered to be part of our galaxy
but Hubble discovered one of these
Cepheid x' in the andromeda nebula and
by using this period-luminosity
relationship he determined that that
star was 2 million light years away so
DN drama that i'm sorry i'm getting over
a cold the Andromeda nebula was actually
a whole new galaxy and he did this with
other galaxies too and that greatly
increased the span and the perceived
size of the universe so if we do this we
need to make some prior work we're gonna
start with the set of image frames and
they need to have some some bits of
calibration done to them and I've talked
about the calibration process in
previous talks and basically we would
have to subtract out noise and try to
flatten the frames out so we can make
comparisons between stars and different
parts of the frames so we have to
subtract out the dark noise and we need
to subtract out flat frames and and they
also need to be pretty well lined
because we're going to be doing like
pixel by pixel comparisons and we'll
talk a little bit more about the
alignment later in the talk and there's
also another type of noise called bias
noise but we don't have to worry about
that for this sort of calculation
because that just gets subtracted out
when we do the photometry
so the basic technique we're going to
use is we're going to divide the area
around our variable star into three
regions and the star itself is gonna be
inside the center red disk which is
called the star aperture and we need to
get an idea of what the intrinsic sky
brightness is behind the star because
that would interfere with the signal so
we have to subtract that out and that'll
be measured inside the blue annulus
which is called the sky annulus and just
separate the two we have a gap and we
can adjust the size of each one of these
obviously we need to adjust the size of
the star apertures of the stars entirely
in that and and get a reasonable measure
for the sky annulus so it doesn't cover
up other stars so the star aperture
gives us the photons coming from the
star the sky annulus gets us the sky
brightness and the gap just separates
the two this is where mathematic as
graphics capabilities are very useful
because we can easily generate masks to
do that with just a few lines of code
for instance the star aperture we're
just going to rasterize a rectangle and
put a disk in the center so the sky
annulus rocket rasterize another
rectangle I put an annulus with inner
diameter and outer diameter and to show
you what this looks like I'm going to
show you a picture easily recognizable
picture of some peppers some of our
example days so if we make sure we image
multiply the peppers by the star
mask you'll see it just isolates the
center portion of the peppers if we
multiply it times the sky annulus I'll
give us this ring outside the center
portion and the difference is this the
SCAP region right here
so now that we have those things we can
do some computations first of all we're
not interested in the whole image that
we've taken with our CCD camera we're
just interested in the little bit around
the star so we have a function called
isolate region which is just going to do
an image take on the image and just clip
out a rectangle around the star and then
the photography calculation I'll just
step through this because it's a little
more complicated but it's pretty
straightforward the first thing we do is
we carve out the area around the star we
do isolate region on the full image
that'll give us the base image and then
we get the star image by image
multiplying our star aperture onto the
base image and then we get our annual
this image by multiplying in the sky
annulus times the base image so the
total signal from the star we do a total
a flatten of image data of star image
this is a great thing about Mathematica
it treats images and data practically
the same so we can just take the image
convert it to data and we're in the
realm of mathematics we can flatten it
out and and total it up they'll give us
the total signal from the star same
exact thing for the sky annulus instant
eye total we also need to know what the
areas of the annulus so that's just pi
times the outer diameter squared minus
the inner diameter squared divided by
four and then we can compute the per
pixel sky signal take the star aperture
area the sky background four pixels the
sky toll divided by the sky annulus that
area and then the total signal that
we're looking for
minus the background
is just equal to the star total minus
the star aperture area times the sky
background per pixel I'm gonna trip over
that in just a second here so that's the
bulk of our calculation now that we've
got our our signal data we need to know
when the picture was taken and for this
we're going to use Julian dates and
Julian date is very useful piece of
information for astronomical
observations because it's just the it's
a real number corresponding to the
number of days which have transpired
since a certain time in the past and the
time we take is January 1st 47 13 BC on
the Julian calendar so this is a large
number of days and it's you know the
fractional number of days so if you're
halfway through a day it's something 0.5
now as I said before mathematic is great
for doing astronomical calculations
because we can handle the type of data
that we have in astronomy which we
called Fitz images a Fitz file contains
not just an image or image data but it
contains a whole lot of other stuff
which is in the meta information portion
of the Fitz file so for convenience I
wrote this utility function called load
Fitz object and what this does is it
takes a path to our Fitz file and it
creates an association with two parts
the first part of the image part it just
imports the image data from the Fitz
file and then the meta information part
which imports the meta information to
the Fitz file and it puts that into an
association it keeps them together so we
can get the Julian date and Link it to
the image
now one bit of complexity here is that
there's no good standard inside of fits
files for representing julienned dates
the simplest thing is if the meta
information contains a JD tag which the
answer Julian date so the first thing we
do is we look in the fits object look in
the meta information and see if we have
that JD tag if we got it we're okay
if we don't have it we're gonna try to
whip it up using Mathematica date
functions so that's what this more
complex version is this get Julian date
alt and that here what you can see what
we're doing is we're trying to look for
the date - Bob's tag and if we have that
we split it either by dashes or slashes
and then we look for a time universal
time tag if that's not there we look for
a time obstacle nastiness but luckily we
can put this all together into a date
object and then convert the date object
directly to a Julian date using
functions which are built into
Mathematica so we got the Julian data
anyway so one more bit of complexity
care so now we want to be able to
extract the brightness as a function of
time so we have this this function here
photometry jobs and this will give it a
Fitz object will give it a list of
coordinates in rows and columns where
the star is located a comparision star
coordinates because we've got to make
these observations relative to a non
varying star and the magnitude of the
non Varian star and then the diameter of
the star we're looking at the gap
diameter which is the outer part of the
gap and the sky annulus diameter
so this is pretty straightforward though
first we get the fits object the image
object out of the image we get the
Julian date out of the fits object and
then we do our photometry calculation on
the star and this will give us the
magnitude of the star based on the star
diameter the gap in the sky diameter and
we'll do the same thing to the reference
star find the difference in magnitudes
and then we'll return a list comprised
of the Julian date and the differential
magnitude plus the comparison star
magnitude so now we can now finally we
got those tools put together we can we
can actually crunch some data so right
now I'm using data that came from the
University of Iowa some of our example
data for studying Sophia's
so now we can just use Mathematica to
put all this stuff together so we get
our file names of our directory of our
fits objects here there's star dot FTS
I've loaded the Cepheid images and this
is the region of the sky we're looking
at and University of Iowa has kindly
pointed out where the variable star is
and where a reference star is and we can
take a look at the first of our images
so there's the starfield and if you look
carefully so there's our Cepheid and
there's a reference start over there and
we can pick up the coordinates of this
simply by just clicking on it and using
our coordinates tool to pick out the
rows and columns of our target star and
our reference star so once we got that
we can just and assuming the star fields
are all well aligned we can compute the
photometry on each one of the images and
this will take a few seconds here but
it's pulled those in and it's done the
computation with the reference star at
magnitude 10 the the diameter of the
star mask six pixels an 8 pixel diameter
gap a 20 pixel diameter annulus and it
sorted those by the observation time so
they're all in sequence although not
necessarily evenly spaced and that's a
significant thing let's see yeah so the
first of the data points here you can
see the Julian date is two point four
five four five four times ten to the six
so about two point four five million
days since that time in 4000 BC the
magnitude of the star is ten point seven
two five two at that observation time so
now we're getting somewhere we can
actually plot the light curve and the
way I like to do it is I take the I take
the first date and I subtract those off
and if we plot that we
get the light curve of the star over a
period of twenty or thirty days and you
can see that the period of this and this
is a classic Cepheid light curve the
period is about fourteen some days this
is list lying plot so list line plot I
can I can do just a list plot and let's
see what that looks like oh yeah yeah
yeah right yeah so that that's our data
without the lines it's a little harder
to see the pattern there but that's like
the line plot so if we so now we want to
find out what the what the period is
because that's what we're after so
there's a couple different ways to do
this and the first thing I tried was
just using a find fit on the data and
this will give us so the function I
tried fitting was this MV MV plus a sine
of Omega T plus V and we're looking for
those parameters as a function of time
and have the offset sorted data and this
gives us M V which is the apparent
magnitude of the variable star that's a
one of the things we're looking for
however fine fit isn't the best function
for determining the frequency of a fit
to periodic data and unfortunately we
can't use fast Fourier transforms for
this because those require the data
points to be regularly spaced and
astronomical data is almost by
definition not regularly spaced because
observations will have to be done over a
period of days or weeks there might be
clouds you know
the moon might be up so so we can't do
that but we need another more powerful
tool now luckily we have such a thing
and it's available in our function
repository so what we do use this we
just have to split out the observation
dates and the observation values and we
have to offset them by the mean because
it needs to be zero offset and then we
can use this regular periodic Graham
function which by the way the
mathematics behind a regular periodic
Graham were done specifically to aid the
processing of a periodic astronomical
data and it's available in our function
repository we can go to the page for a
regular periodic Graham and and this
page has tools of good examples for this
and I invite you all to get on this and
play around with it because it's exactly
what we're looking for
so if we use that and and plot it we'll
see that there's a strong peak
corresponding to the fundamental
frequency in the data
it's about point for something radians
and we can use Mathematica determine the
exact position of that peak and its
point four three seven eight to four
radians
radians and and the period you can see
is about fourteen point three five days
which is what we looked at from the
chart up there when I plotted it so the
if we plug this into our distance from
period formula will say that the and
assuming that the observed visual
magnitude is ten point something we can
get the distance in parsecs to the
Cepheid it's about twelve thousand
parsecs
so before I mentioned that this is
dependent on having images which are
rock-solid because we have to compare
this target star from from image to
image and if it swims around its it's
not going to be any good so how do we
solve that problem well real star fields
tend to swim around a bit my colleague
Jeff here has graciously loaned me some
of the images that he took during his
graduate work of variable stars this is
not a Cepheid it's it's a it clicked
eclipsing cataclysmic variable star and
this is what it looks like you can see
it fading in and out there it's right
there in the center but it's also kind
of swimming around and why does it do
that well it's because astronomical
instruments are have errors in their
gear trains and even with with good
tracking you're gonna see still see a
little bit of a variation in position
and in order to solve this problem we
need to align the images and we can do
this again using Mathematica z-- image
processing capabilities now I'm not
going to walk all through this because
I've talked about this before and other
talks but we can use Mathematica to pick
out features in this case the stars and
then from that extract a set of
transforms which we can apply to
successive frames
and once we have done that we can and
there's some additional functions we can
use that to to align a series of star
frames like for instance here is an
image of BL cantaloupe Pardo and you can
see that it's it's swimming around a
little bit but after we apply this
alignment function to it you can see
it's it's Rocksteady you can see they're
fading in and out a little bit but I
haven't done any more processing on
these things and and we could do more
work on that so that's and you can see
that we can do an image adjust on that
and then if we extract the light curve
from this and it'd be better if we had
more good images so we can get a better
light curve but you can see that that
we're getting this is more typical of
data than you might get and if you have
a lot of things and you feed them into
the periodic Graham function we can get
a pretty good idea of what the period of
this is and for that we can extract data
about the light curve and you can use
these same techniques as I said before
to extract other types of light curves
like light curves that come from
eclipsing binaries or from exoplanets so
and but that's really a subject for a
later talk and and and so I think that's
about all I want to say for right now
so I think I think we got a maybe a
minute or so for questions it's it's a
little hard to say it's because I don't
have enough images in this data set I
just kind of pulled this off the
internet but you can see it's it's part
of a like curve of some this is more
typical and and when real astronomers do
the sort of work they they collect
hundreds of images may be from different
telescopes on these things and and so
what you see is a very heavily populated
light curve and then you can extract a
very good set of data from that and find
a good period I'm getting to that
as I said I'm an amateur astronomer so
I'm constrained by things like clouds
and trees and and stuff but I plan on
doing that this spring yes sir I think
they did the way they would do this is
is for my limited knowledge as they
would look at plates and then they had
comparison images of like stars of
different brightness so they could say
you know if they want to extract me the
magnitude of the star they would compare
it to a comparison plate and say this is
the stars about this magnitude and
that's how they got the magnitude
information but you can imagine doing
that for you know the dozens of these
big glass plates and it with a
microscope and it's it really makes you
respect the efforts of these people who
did this right right so they would have
to extract this data and then from
hundreds of observations you can get
information about the period of the
variable star
any other questions okay well I think
really
[Applause]